but this is a reception hosted in
Buckingham Palace behind me last night
with a queen's consort was receiving a
number of uh Charities and people who
work with survivors of domestic abuse
one of those who was in attendance was
ngozi Fulani the chief executive of
sister space Britain's leading domestic
abuse charity that predominantly helps
black women and this was a conversation
that Miss villani said happened between
her and a member of the royal household
when she was asked where she was from
Miss fellani had said East London
specifically Brixton and this was the
response from a member of how the Royal
household who went on to say she says no
what part of Africa are you from I don't
know they didn't leave any records said
Miss villani well you must know where
you're from I spent time in France where
are you from
Miss felani said here UK no but what
nationality are you Miss villani went on
to say I am born Here I Am British no
but where do you really come from where
do your people come from my people lady
what is this
well this allegedly happened at this
event last night just before the event
itself happened and Miss felani said on
social media that the next few hours
passed with a bit of a blur she said she
felt incredibly insulted by the comments
and has it's left her feeling
traumatized we have heard from a
spokesperson from Buckingham Palace who
has said in a statement in this instance
unacceptable and deeply regrettable
comments have been made
we have reached out and gozi Fulani on
this matter and are inviting her to
discuss all elements of her experience
in person if she wishes in the meantime
the individual concerned would like to
express her profound apologies for the
hurt caused and has stepped aside from
her honorary role with immediate effect
so an uncomfortable position for the
palace and a mission though that these
comments in their opinion too were
indeed unacceptable that member of Staff
who's alleged to have taken past this
conversation has indeed resigned with
immediate effect